three-quarters of republicans think that
the riot
the capitol hill riot was not trump
supporters
out there they think it was
actually liberals and democrats dressed
up as them
making them i'm not making this up
trying to make trump look bad
that we dress up as them so i just want
to say to conservatives
you got us
you got us that's what we do
[Applause]
we do it um we do it we dress up like
you
uh there's a costume department at
george soros's house
uh tim robbins and i do the sewing
and there's even a catalog now false
flag supply
uh if you wanna as a liberal dress up to
make trump look bad
just get the stuff here we have some of
the things for example you could get
this this distressed
maga hat this is great because you want
it to look like
you know you've had it for a while uh
but if you really uh if you really want
to do well
look like them get this trump maga hat
with the mullet
with the mullet built into it you see
there you go
and then there's the uh if you really
want to seal the deal
you know dress up like them uh cause
it's all in the details
uh get these meth keys
and then if you really want to sell it
okay so you know i mean a lot of the
people who are trump supporters they
blow up their hand
setting off firecrackers and doing other
hold my beard dares
so you get this fake
rubber hand with the missing finger you
see
[Applause]
uh and then
you're also gonna need you know a lot of
the liberals were too in shape they get
the trump gut
you know you put this right
there's also oh this the uh oh you want
you want a misspelled hand sign
this is
oh again yeah it's in the details
you want your copy of the constitution
they always carry a copy
make sure it's still in the packaging
because they've never read it that's
that's very
important and
finally not to leave the ladies out of
this you want
these are terrific these are mike pence
earrings
where he's you see he's hanging
[Applause]
okay
you